Semantic similarity used with conceptual similarity between the target problem
and the source case. If we recall the original exercise that David had answered,
in that exercise, a woman climbing up a ladder is conceptually similar,
semantically similar to a woman climbing up a step ladder.
The same kind of concepts occur in both situations. Woman, and step ladder or
ladder. Pragmatic similarity concerns with external factors.
Factors external to the presentation, such as goals. As an example,
in the Dunker radiation problem, the physician had a goal of killing the tumor,
which was similar to the goal of capturing the fort in case of the rebel army
and the king. Pragmatic similarity refers to similarity of external factors,
factors external to the representation, such as similarity of goals. The Dunker
radiation problem for example, the physician had the goal of killing the tumor,
which was similar to the goal of capturing the fort in case of the rebel army in
the king example. The third measure of similarity is structural similarity.
Structure here refers to the structure of presentations,
not to physical structure. Now structural similarity of the first two,
similarity between the representational structures of the target problem and
the source case, and we'll look at an example of this in just a few minutes.
Know that one can assign different kinds of weights to these three measures of
similarity. So some queries of analogy focus on structural similarity.
Other theories of analogy focus on semantic and
pragmatic similarity. That is also why you may have given slightly different
answers to the questions in the first exercise than David did.